it was the most dramatic moment in
recent television history i think that's
fair to say uh we need to get right into
what went down between will smith and
chris rock during the oscars ceremony
carlos i still can't believe this
happened so in case you haven't seen it
i'm sure you've seen it will stormed on
stage and smacked the comedian after he
made a joke alluding to jada pickett
smith's bald head the whole moment was
muted on the broadcast but the
uncensored exchange was captured via
japanese television take a look
[Applause]
wow
[Applause]
will smith just smacked out of me
[Applause]
wow dude
yeah it was a gi jane jump keep my wife
look at her no i'm going to okay
oh yeah let's sink in for a second yeah
uh so
i mean clearly the joke did not go over
well now chris mentioned that jada looks
like she could star in gig into making a
joke about her bald head meanwhile jada
has been very open about her hair loss
battle as she suffers from alopecia now
shortly after this moment went down will
took home the night's top actor prize
for his role as venus and serena
williams father in king richard during
his acceptance speech will broke down as
he seemingly apologized seemingly for
the shocking incident
to do what we do
you got to be able to take
abuse you got to be able to have people
talk crazy about you
in this business you got to be able to
have
people disrespecting you
and you got to smile and you got to
pretend like that's okay i want to
apologize to the academy i want to
apologize to my all my fellow
nominees
now will also said that he hopes the
academy invites him back and explained
that denzel washington pulled him aside
after the heated moment and warned him
be careful at your highest moment that's
when the devil comes for you now a lot
has happened since then the entire smith
family arrived all smiles at the vanity
fair oscar party as will proudly showed
off his new hardware our will's son
jaden also stood behind his dad on
twitter simply writing and that's how we
do it and stars like henry golding
tiffany haddish and caramel brown
reacted to will's outburst on the vanity
fair red carpet
[Music]
i think that both legends i think i
think
there's something deeper sort of uh to
be discussed and i hope they they both
step up man-to-man and
kind of figure it all out which i i'm
sure they will
i wish i had a man to protect me like
that
yeah i think i think what we need to
learn like is that as celebrities we
look at them as if they're not human
beings and sometimes we hope we
hopefully poke and tonight was a high
emotion night for will smith regardless
and i think we have to sometimes
remember like at a certain point
everyone breaks but i think these are
two men that will actually come together
figure it out and like say okay enough
is enough i'm sorry you know what i mean
um but you know you
i you know i haven't been in that
situation i never condone violence or
anything other nature but i also can
understand protecting those you love
now the academy has released a statement
following the incident saying this the
academy does not condone violence of any
form tonight we are delighted to
celebrate our 94th academy award awards
winner who deserve this moment of
recognition from their peers and movie
lovers around the world among many
people weighing in online rosie
o'donnell slam the academy exclusive
excuse me slam the academy for doing
nothing the ladies of the view also
addressed the much talked about moment
with whoopi goldberg saying will
overreacted but insists they will not
take away that oscar from him
i was
embarrassed for for will
i was horrified for chris rock i mean
we'll apologize to the academy and he
apologized to uh his colleagues and the
other nominees but he didn't apologize
to chris rock no and i thought chris was
the one that um deserved an apology for
taking the high road
i think he overreacted
i get it
not everybody acts the way we would like
them to under pressure some people just
snap he snapped
what i do want to say is i think it's
remarkable and wonderful that chris rock
did not take it
to that other place it could have gone
yeah we're not going to take that oscar
from him well we're not going to tell
you there's just consequences too well
there will be consequences i'm sure but
i don't think that that's what they'll
particularly because chris said listen
i'm not i'm not pressing anything
and now according to page six will and
chris did make amends after the incident
with sean diddy combs telling the outlet
that's not a problem that's over i can
confirm that it's all love they're
brothers and we can confirm chris
declined to take legal action after the
slap with lapd stating that they were
aware of the incident but the individual
involved quote the individual involved
has the client to file a police report
chris has not yet publicly commented on
the situation uh i mean we're all
waiting for that i'm sure sangeeta oh
there's so much to break down first of
all i'm just gonna set it back to where
i was watching it yesterday here out in
the studio and watching the show and it
was doing its thing and then when that
moment happened i didn't realize the
joke until
will decided well will started laughing
yes right he was laughing everyone was
laughing jada made a face and then will
got up and slapped him so i wasn't sure
if that was real until he went back and
the camera was on him and it went mute
and that's when i realized this is for
real this is actually happening
the whole situation is so interesting
because once that happened everything
was overshadowed we didn't care what was
happening at that point who's winning
you know koda had a big night liza
minnelli was there all these moments
that we missed
and then his speech and you were we were
talking about this i i kept watching the
speech and every word he was saying one
of the things that got to me was that he
was comparing himself to king rich's
father and in the movie there's a scene
where he's getting beaten up and he's
not he doesn't hit back yeah right and
in the situation so that wasn't great
for venus and serena
two when he says love makes you do crazy
things yeah it really bothered me
because this is now being put on jada
and it's not jada even if she it's all
will this was his decision yeah anger
makes you crazy not loved
and so his reaction was for himself and
he thought he's protecting her jada may
not need it so this i don't want this to
fall on jada this was all will's doing
um it is a moment that i you violence is
not the answer even if you snap i don't
we talked about this how would you
respond to it
you don't go after someone like that you
don't slap chris rock the anger i know
if he was yelling i'm like i understand
that but the slapping part was not not
right so
protecting he used words like that he
talked about abuse he talked about you
know all these words that just really
infuriated me in his speech because it
wasn't acknowledging what the moment was
yeah this has become this sort of like
lightning rod conversation for people
online a lot of people taking that
stance of like
you know you shouldn't turn to violence
this was the wrong thing to do other
people saying like
um
like tiffany had a [ __ ] said i wish
someone would do that for me sort of
thing
you know the thing that got me
i i didn't like seeing it it i was i was
embarrassed too and disappointed um and
i understand that there is a divide
between the public persona that you put
forward and the person you are and the
things that you're going through um that
will smith and his family and jada tend
to be very very open
about what they're going through which
invites a lot of scrutiny and he kind of
addressed that in his speech one of the
things that really bothered me the most
actually was that and people are talking
about it here in the comments too it's
like
this has become the only thing that
people are talking about and there were
so many great moments that happened last
night um troy kotzer are one of the bose
winning kidding me like just phenomenal
people who did phenomenal work getting
recognized for it and and you know um
ariane dubose being the first openly
queer person to to win this particular
award too like
history making stuff
and this
moment of just like
impulse yeah and not being able to in
the moment think of a better way to
handle
being angry i guess
um is the thing that is
the only thing anyone's talking about
yeah and i and i think though also the
moment we don't see it on camera what
triggered him because when he was
laughing and she had that face something
happened there for him to get up there
the joke was wrong i mean she's been
talking about alopecia for almost a year
and i'm sure he knew if he didn't i mean
or he didn't maybe he didn't i didn't
know
jane
2 joke um but he could have handled it
better and the other part of this whole
thing it was will smith's night we knew
he was gonna win best actor like this
was his moment uh the first black man in
14 or 15 years to get an award the fifth
black man to get an oscar award like
this is a huge moment he's like we
talked about it he's the next one in
line after denzel washington denzel was
supporting him he was in the same
category and it was overshadowed by this
moment uh some people are saying you
know we've been reading a lot of
comments saying they should be you know
you shouldn't have the oscar anymore the
other part of that was frustrating we're
going to keep going on about the story
for sure
is that he was at vanity fair after
party celebrating and and he was with
his family and the way his son responded
on twitter this is how we handle it no
you don't handle it with violence um you
know these are the things that are
adding up i don't know if he's going to
come out of this like how do you handle
the situation now like where do you go
from here uh i and you like you said red
red table talk that you have a very open
conversation and it opens up to people
making comments uh rick chris rock he's
a comedian yeah this is his job he makes
he made a lot of jokes right before that
and other things i hear it keep going
regina paul also made a comment about
their infidelity off the top they were
laughing at that right
so it's it's a bit of a mess but i think
at the end of day i'm not sure a lot of
i think a lot of people lost respect for
will smith yeah i can see that too and i
you know
for better or worse and a lot of people
will say this is for worse but it often
what ends up happening next depends on
who falls on what side right right and
so um
a lot of people love will smith we know
that there are a lot of fans that
support him yeah
even like taking his side and in this
particular action and uh
famous powerful people that probably
feel the same way
um
whoopi said there will be consequences
i'm curious to see what will become of
it
i like the idea if it is real that there
has been
um
conversation between chris and will and
that the things have been sorted out i
don't know if that's really real or not
but in my mind if it is that's a that's
a wonderful thing
um this also goes back to 2016 when
chris rock was the host on oscars and he
made fun of or made jokes about jada
pika smith at the time as well they were
funny jokes they were you know at the
time right it worked at the time so we
don't know apparently they didn't get
along after that after that whole
situation and there was ups and downs
with the relationship apparently we
don't know if that is true or not um so
maybe there was an underlying situation
that we didn't know about but still the
way it was handled at the end of the day
was not the greatest way is i don't know
what people are saying we would love to
hear from you on your thoughts on this
uh but this is a very
historic moment just kind of took it
away from everybody from a lot of people
there's i mean a lot of the comments
here are in line with what the
conversation we're having here uh
conversation excuse me that we are
having here um
carla says oh carlos says will's
narcissism embarrassed the movie the
williams family and his own family
a lot of people just like like wtf
roxanna says bad joke however his
reaction no no
reena says ruined the moment for quest
love yeah as well yes who went for
for best documentary i mean it's it
really
and again people are talking about this
in the comments too that what we are
doing right now in
talking about this so much
is that thing that takes the energy away
from
all the accomplishments that people had
last night but
like we just said when you're there
and you know what's at stake for so many
people in the room
[Music]
and you know that one thing that you're
going to do is going to change the
course of conversation moving forward
like did you stop and think about that
and also being in the position that
you're in
um i don't know if anybody ever says to
himself i want to be a role model and
i'm going to be right and he is but
you're put in a position
where you know but he inspires
everything he does on social media he is
an inspirational he inspires me like he
does some crazy stuff out there and i'm
like i can do that too like he's that
guy that's who will smith is and him
being like a sole person he believes in
all of this and to be able to come out
and do that and slap someone is it's a
[ __ ] i mean whether we like it or not
there will be a lot of conversation
going on about this and we'll be waiting
to see what happens
with chris and will and how they talk
about that moving forward i think i
wonder where chris was afterwards you
know p diddy said that he was or sean
pete what's his name now sean pitt did
he come go i'm calling i don't know what
his name is
but he said they're getting along so did
he end up going to the party as well did
he celebrate but uh the whole situation
i think at the end of the day i think uh
will should have acknowledged it in his
speech i know he was apologizing in a
certain way well too like i'm into the
academy and to the people there yeah